what makes 99 of screenplays unreadable
i think it's it might be the story it
depe probably everyone is
there's a different problem with them
but they all have problems because i've
seen a lot of these
but what you need to think about too is
the reader they don't think about who's
reading it
and the person reading it if they're
professional has a stack of scripts
you know sky-high in their office so you
need to understand
like if you don't grab the person the
first two three pages
you know and you hear this all the time
but sometimes you even need to like have
something happen that might not happen
like that in the film
like you know is there a scene you know
on page
23 that's super exciting okay why not
put that
two or three pages of our section of it
at the very beginning and then
create a flashback or do something so
that the
it's exciting and really reads like a
professional script at the very
beginning
and that's the other thing it has to
read like a professional script which
means the dialogue has to be
well executed it has to move it has to
have beats you don't want to get bogged
down in minutia
you don't want to you know do exposition
you have to
show don't tell but the thing is it's
not hard to get copies of screenplays
nowadays because the internet has
everything
so there's a movie like your movie see
how they did it you know but you have to
really grab people right away it has to
be
you know professional all the way
through but if it's not professional
first five pages they're just gonna you
know be like
what is this you know and you're asking
someone
you know to take an hour two hours out
of their life to read your script so it
better be perfect
you know and you better really do your
work or else you're wasting people's
time
is that when a script consultant might
be helpful
because let's suppose everyone you know
is going to just tell you it's great
and they've never met written a movie
before yeah
a script consultant could be helpful um
there's some things you just intuitively
either are going to figure out or you're
not
but you know you can you can get a
script consultant to take you maybe to
the next level or show you things you're
doing wrong
like i said my view on that is is
they're good as long as you don't spend
a lot of money
because i've had people come to me
asking me to fix a script or
saying hey can you do this i spent fifty
thousand dollars on this script i paid
somebody to go to write it and they're
like somebody's never written a script
so you have to be very careful that you
don't you know
lose your ass financially so um but you
know
it could help you know there's so many
classes out there there's so many things
but
i just always go back to watch movies
they're there
they show you how to do it it's already
been done for you
you know and just figure out how your
story fits into that formula and just
kind of like
find those beats but that's why i think
why 99
of scripts are just they're not ready
and they're not at a professional level
you know if you get there it takes a lot
of work to get it there
and do you think that people gave up too
soon on some of those
unreadable scripts or that there's just
no way to sort of it's just lipstick on
a pig you can't really fix it
yeah probably probably both but i think
a lot of it's just not doing the work
you know you just
it's not some magic thing you know i
think people have this you know
you know they envision you know smoking
cigarettes writing in the middle of the
night you know
like it's glamorous it's not glamorous
it's like if you really want to get good
at the people who make a living in it
are people who just you know stick to it
you know grind it out
rewrite it rewrite it rewrite the other
day i found there was a project i found
like
let's clean out my computer i found like
40 drafts of the script
you know it's like that's a lot of
drafts
so you know and that's what you have to
do is really grind it and
work on it and make sure you know you
get the professional level and like i
said you can
find all these scripts online you know
if it's anything that's similar
you can find it if you you know you want
to do a movie about
a guy in a food truck you know john
favreau did chef
watch that you know you know by the way
he's one of the best that like
beats in a film watch his films they all
have the same rhythm and the same beats
it's there
yeah i love chef that was great yeah so
you saved each draft
of that screenplay you did it for you
you had 40 drafts and you saved each one
this is you know just date them now
because there's so many on so many
things
so yeah what's the purpose of saving
each draft
of a revision just to kind of keep track
you know i mean probably not really
anything you know
that has to do with screenwriting just
that's my process it's just easier to
kind of like
you know i also back everything up on
email and things like that and
another backup but but you know you
never know when you need it or go back
to something that like you took out
so i sometimes get a little crazy to
start cutting stuff out too
i can i can like just chop chop chop
and then sometimes i chop too much so
i'll be like oh wait that was good
what was that one scene where the guy
couldn't aim the gun because he was
shaking
i cut that out so i'll go back to older
version and find it just cut and paste
it back in
what really irritates you about reading
other screenplays
what irritates me is just when people
haven't done
got it to where it should be at a level
of reading you know where they send you
something and they go oh don't read that
wait i got this one or i changed that or
you or do you read it you talk to them
they're like oh i changed that
it's like well that means you know there
was that famous josh
olson article which you can find online
um
about reading people's scripts which you
know it's like if it's not ready to be
read
don't send it to me because it's like
like josh had mentioned it's like
asking somebody come over to your house
and paint for two hours you know you're
taking up two hours of somebody's time
you know so don't give it to them to
read until it's like
perfect and there you know and if you
want my notes and i give you some notes
don't be defensive about it either
that's the most irritating thing it's
like don't say i want
i want your opinion and then you give
somebody opinion or you say you need to
fix this
okay great thanks and they're they have
an attitude about it
it's like you know why'd you have me
read it just tell you it's great
is it okay to question why you gave a
certain note
is that yeah oh yeah definitely
definitely yeah
oh yeah of course and and you know what
do i know as much as i know i don't know
anything
so it's like you know sometimes my notes
might not even be
valid it's just this is what i think you
know but sometimes people don't even
want to hear that they just want they
just want you to tell them it's great
did you ever catch that in yourself and
really work on that it sounds like
you're okay with
with negative feedback um it gets easier
you know so i mean it all kind of
depends on who it comes from too
it's like you know i mean if if somebody
reads a script of mine that's like
never written a script and they were
like i don't like this and that
i mean probably my knee jerk reaction
like what do you know but
if it's a producer somebody who i
respect and who's done
a lot of work then i listen to him but
it does get easier to take the negative
feedback and like
like i said before it's about
interpreting notes too sometimes
people can't explain why they don't like
something
and you have to figure that out would
you say that 99
of what hollywood makes is garbage no
there's some garbage but but no
i think i think most films i mean most
films get started with very good
intentions
and look i've made a few movies that i'm
not happy with either but the process is
not a singular process you have to deal
with producers actors
you know money guys distributors like
even the nic cage movie that i wrote
it wasn't called rage the distributor
called it rage you know it's like really
rage
okay nobody's gonna make fun of rage in
the cage you know but i had no control
over that
so it you lose so much control in the
process
that you know it takes a very very
strong
director like somebody like quentin
tarantino who can say no to everybody
and filter out the bad that comes along
you know that's
you know you're making you're doing art
by committee so that's why sometimes
things
they have great intentions maybe it was
a great script maybe the actor was
amazing but things got messed up
along the way because there's so many
people's hands on the editor
you know the composer the director
there's
the screenwriter the producer who shows
up on set and wants to put a motorcycle
chase in the middle of the movie that
makes no sense and then you find out
later it's because he can get a free bmw
motorcycle if we
put him in the movie things like that
happen so you know that's why sometimes
movies don't work out but i think
most screenwriters and directors almost
all of them have
the intention to make a great movies
just things get in the way or lack of
money
or resources so if someone's at a
certain level then there's
so much more creative control because
they can basically say no to people you
need that like one per that's why
score says you can make but you need a
strong director or writer director who
can
like no one's going to question that
because then it at least
keeps everything focused there's very
few of those people you know but like i
think paul thomas anderson i don't think
any producers are going to show up or
money guys and tell them what to do
you know so it's or quentarantino or
christopher nolan that's why they can
make really great films
because the white noise that's going on
around them they can just stop
you know or just ignore it or people
just scared even you know mess with them
because people want to get their ideas
into film too you'll have you know money
guys who you've never even
met who gave some money on a film show
up and like give an idea
and then other ones are great and
actually have good ideas so you know
there's just so many people that are
involved in a film that
it's hard sometimes to keep it focused
so i think that's the problem with
things that sometimes because there's a
lot of moves on netflix you know
look like they had good intentions and
like i said i've i've worked on a few
that like
start off over here and ended up over
there you know
it happens
you